à travers des jardins des oeuvres des
installations cette année le festival
des jardins de chaumont-sur-loire à un
but faire découvrir le biomimétisme
c'est à dire la façon dont la nature
peut inspirer de nouveaux modes de
fonctionnement
la nature est une grande bibliothèque et
dans cette bibliothèque on peut trouver
beaucoup de réponse est peut-être tout
les prêts les réponses à nos
préoccupations
le biomimétisme une notion pas forcément
connus de tous les visiteurs mais que
ces oeuvres rendre plus concrète
quand on voit la la ça nous paraît
tellement évident voilà c'est vraiment
une belle découverte ça invite à pousser
plus loin la logique qu'on peut avoir
lorsqu'on fait des choix de de
consommation des choix de production de
l'environnement et ça oui ça invite à
pousser encore plus comme avec cette
installation inspirée par un oiseau
australien le jardinier satiné qui
récupèrent des objets bleus pour
construire son nid vers ce qu'il est
amoureux un comportement qui invite au
recyclage
parce que si on fait attention on a
beaucoup d'objets dans notre proche
environnement qu'on n'utilise pas qu'on
a jetée etc
et si on adoptait l'attitude de ce
jardinier c'est inné on perdrait
beaucoup moins de choses et on
recyclerait mieux le recyclage mais
aussi la récupération de l'eau ou encore
le respect d'une bonne cohabitation
entre les arbres autant d'exemples qui
met en lumière
l'intelligence de la nature une
intelligence naturellement respectueuse
de l'environnement